it's time for drew's news your daily
frolic in the good news meadow and with
me at the desk my little doe-eyed news
dear rossi ross matthews that's right hi
everybody hi
[Applause]
roxy and i love to color coordinate yeah
i was real proud of this one i gotta say
i know this one's really on point
um well we are celebrating siblings all
day and uh while you're my news brother
from another mother your actual brother
is here rossie yeah everyone
my brother right here
hi
good to see you
it's so good to see you look everyone
that's what i look like if i were
straight
my brother got on a plane and flew all
the way here from california just to be
on our sibling show with all of you eric
thank you for coming here i love it
thank you
the best
i am a lucky man i am in many ways you
know eric and i um are we've lost both
their parents and we were not like super
close growing up and
it has been the most
surprising gift in my adulthood to bond
with you and become like best friends
with you as a brother you learn i think
as you get older how important your
family is and now that we have less than
ever
i know for sure how grateful i am to
have you in my life i feel the same way
buddy oh this is the best episode of dr
phil ever thank you so much
i love it i'm so glad you're here eric
happy siblings day thank you yeah it's
wonderful all right well i want to hear
a brotherly take on this first story
let's get into the headlines
lifestyle site her reports psychologists
say when it comes to birth order the
young one is the fun one
oh really apparently experts say the
youngest is the happy-go-lucky one
because parents ran out of steam when it
came to disciplining
i also think like parents relax a lot i
mean i was so neurotic with my first
daughter
and she's intense like i think both of
us were like you know anyway the
youngest are often charismatic uh
extroverted creative mischievous
boisterous and adventurous well the
oldest can be stubborn motivated and
very independent wow this i mean that
wow
that is
yeah okay
uh matthews brothers does this check out
well i'm gonna end the suspense right
now and confirm yes i am the youngest
thank you for noticing and that's true i
uh i came out of my mother's womb like a
human karaoke machine it was like
too much like can you tone it down ross
and so eric i'm sorry i'm sorry for the
whole childhood thing i at least got to
teach you what not to do with all of my
screw-ups so you're welcome
but you you are right about mom
okay well you look at these pictures
drew this is me in a wig uh and my
brother looking at me like oh he's
probably going to be on rupaul's drag
race oh my god
that's right winning emmy is drunk
there's uh winning emmys yeah it's not
crazy i still have that wig too don't i
still do have that wig unfortunately but
i do think there there's something to it
i mean everybody here started agreeing
in the audience that the younger kid
sort of is louder why why is that you
think i have no idea i'm not a sibling
as i've established here on the show but
this is definitely true for olive and
frankie show of hands who thinks the
younger one is like a little bit of the
freer one oh definitely
why do you think that is do you think
it's because of the parents
i do i i think what you said like you i
can't imagine the first day you bring
that baby home you're like where is the
user's manual i have no clue what to do
and by the time you have that second one
you're like it's cool i didn't screw up
the first one
[Applause]
all right
well right next uh writer taylor andrews
at cosmopolitan has a fascinating new
piece of dating criteria for everybody
to consider she says when you look at a
potential partner you should look for
something called r w r-w-s-e which means
raised with sister's energy
interesting yes okay we've got some
sisters in the house who agree
well the author argues that people with
sisters have deeper emotional
intelligence and experts back her up
they say people with sisters can be more
communicative empathetic and better at
compromise
some people we know with rwse michael b
jordan dakota fanning harry styles
i have to say i don't have a sister but
i was surrounded by
nothing but like friends who were girls
and extraordinarily strong women i can
say firsthand women are better than men
they
i i said it as a man
they are empathetic and caring and
nurturing there is something very
the way human beings should be are what
women are and i think that i soaked up a
little bit of that being around women
and i think i'm the better for it you
soaked up so much of it okay ross your
story wedding site one fab day tackled
this interesting question do i need to
have my brother as my best man
the well speaker said no
well the answer is short this author
says no not unless you want to if your
brother isn't the right fit there are
plenty other jobs at the wedding ring
bearer uh flower boy i don't know katuba
signer yeah thank you so much your
perfect best man should be whoever makes
you feel the most comfortable and
supported
and
that being said
[Music]
eric
i will be your flower boy yes i will
eric
i wanted to ask you
in front of everybody
you know we are planning our wedding
right now i do
wellington and i have discussed it drew
kindly let me come on the show so i
could ask you in front of the world will
you be my best man
absolutely thank you i'd be honored too
my god
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you i love you remember how i told
you i love drew's news
this is why thank you eric and thank you
rossie we'll be right back
[Music]